in the market square of the little town
of kalamata the stage is ready for the
arrival of socialist opposition leader
Alexis tsipras the area is buzzing with
people who are fed up with the
established parties at the on view if
Prime Minister Antonis Samaras and his
people win it will have an even worse
effect on Europe Alexis tsipras as a
young man and we have high hopes for him
people should give see put us a chance
they will see if things go uphill or
downhill for us when he finally takes to
the stage tsipras receives a hero's
welcome the young politician is
charismatic but unapproachable he's been
entered into the race for president of
the european commission and we've lined
up an interview to talk to him about his
candidacy but he is focused on other
things in his speech he lists europe's
flaws sharply criticizing the austerity
measures imposed on his country he
describes the consequences as a social
Holocaust and angela merkel as his main
opponent he refers to the german
chancellor eight times and warns of a
German Europe there's no mention of
specific election goals and there is no
interview
we follow him to Athens where there is
little sign of the battle for power and
distant Brussels
many Greeks blamed the EU for the misery
in their country and tsipras promises to
throw the IMF the World Bank and EU
financial backers out of the country but
then what only engines is not bullied
bullies you know there is not enough
Vanessa cats rd will give Alexis tsipras
and his left-wing syriza her vote the
university lecturer and mother of two
has been out of work for two years she
believes tsipras is the only one who
really dares to challenge those
responsible for the current crisis
Valadez honestly I believe in Europe I
want to change Europe and and change the
way of thinking and move it towards the
people and less towards you know the
companies and the banks and everything
so I think that the giving vote to more
leftist parties we will we will give
that era that new era to Europe tsipras
auntie German campaign can be felt in
unexpected ways like from this election
helper I don't want to district to
German channel ok
tsipras plans on running in Greece's
next parliamentary election in 2016 with
hopes of becoming Prime Minister the
polls put him neck and neck with the
current head of government antonis
samaras critics believe he would even
form a coalition with right-leaning
parties if it got him into power its
esteemed paleta forgot he's doubtless
politically talented afghan amin phone
he's increased the series of parties
following from three to more than twenty
percent to get for part time it's fancy
good off but i think his populism and
his opportunism work against him pople
is most on 20 botanist most this
promotional film is testimony to the
statesman like way in which tsipras
portrays himself abroad although he's
known to shy away from media attention
we're still waiting for our interview
and have followed the candidate to a
packed Athens theater his speech which
is broadcast live on television is
another critique of the neoliberal
politics he says have spilled Greek
blood and caused Greek pain even he
points to the current thirty percent
unemployment rate and says Europe needs
a new deal in the form of justice
after his speech he takes questions we
ask exactly what he would change as
president of the european commission i
will try to ask for a European summit
for the public debt for the European
periphery in the model of the London
assignment of 9053 but they decide to
cancel eight the sixty percent of the
public debt of Germany after the Second
World War and they the main victim of
the austerity and the Bourbon measures
is democracy itself and then he goes on
his way the candidate for the European
left-wing whose real goal is to become
the next prime minister of Greece